[Music]
Jessie on Disney Channel was one of
these TV shows that we all loved and
that our parents hated that's because
there were a lot of jokes that only our
mother and father really understood and
they thought that it was really
inappropriate just wait until you hear
what kids were watching in health class
we can't believe that a Disney Channel
show got away with that if you love
Jessie as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we're showing you
ten inappropriate jokes in Jesse the
Moon when watching this video you'll
notice that most of the inappropriate
jokes come from the king of comedy
himself Luke Ross when Zuri decided to
hire Jesse as her new nanny
she quickly discovered that she had
three other crazy siblings Emma asked
her brother to give her back her moon
and he didn't want to let her have it
Emma insisted by saying that she needed
it for her solar system and this was
when the young boy told her that he was
going to show her the moon then he tried
to pull down his pants before his sister
pushed him on the couch if you know what
a moon is you know which body part Luke
wanted to show his sister and that's
something that neither his family and
the viewers want to see this young kid
looked like a real troublemaker until he
realized that his new nanny was actually
really cute he tried to impress her and
that's when Jessie replied that she was
way too old for him then a lot of
awkward jokes about his interest in her
followed he even said that their date
was a waste of clean underwear as if she
was supposed to see it after dinner or
maybe because they're not clean anymore
Luke might want to give her the moon to
show how much he wants to be with her
but once again we don't think that this
is what a lady really wants the date
just when you thought that Jessie had
the control of the situation things got
worse and yes we're still talking about
the first episode when Luke first saw
Jessie it was love at first sight or
should we say of her biddin love as he
likes to call it that didn't keep him
from inviting her on a date he put on
his best looking suit and brought her
flowers but as we expected it wasn't
enough to seduce her at least there is
one lucky guy who got the chance to be
invited to go on a date with Jessie or
should we say one lucky thing Emma's
parents couldn't make it to see her
science project because they were
working on a movie this is why the new
nanny decided to go on set to make them
change their minds a guy wouldn't let
her go near them so she put on a costume
and pretended to be an extra this was
when she started being attacked by a
huge tentacle it pulled her up in the
air and the poor young woman started
screaming that didn't keep her from
being funny as she asked it to at least
buy her dinner first is that really what
you get for offering food to Jessie it
seems like Luke knows about that at the
end of the episode he said that after
dinner they could and Jesse stopped him
before his hand touched her bottom
forget it freckles the photographer and
here's another inappropriate joke Luke
is responsible for we all know that this
young boy is madly in love with Jessie
and that doesn't keep him from
misbehaving because that's the reason
why she gives him a lot of attention in
this episode the talented mr. Kipling
Luke was really happy to have the
opportunity to take pictures of
beautiful girls for his photography
class and as we could imagine he wanted
his crush Jessie to be his muse and
Jessie wasn't ready for this at all this
is why she asked Luke if he had an off
switch and he answered by asking her if
she wanted to find it we all know what
it means the switch on this young
teenagers body is already on and the
fastest way to turn it off is by
touching it until he doesn't have any
energy left and this is something no one
wants to think about so we're really
happy that Jessie immediately said no we
really don't know what to do with these
kids and those hormones but we have to
admit that we have a dirty mind too if
you want to see another lucky
photographer just wait until you watch
the following episode Ravi used a
telescope to look at a photographer
taking pictures of girls wearing nothing
but triangles and we know why Luke was
so interested unfortunately that wasn't
the kind of breasts he was thinking
about put on a shirt Bertram where Luke
comes from since the first episodes
we've been wondering how two white
parents could have four children of
different origins the answer was really
simple Emma was the only biological
child and the three others were adopted
also working in the film industry the
two parents were like Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie but we've always been
wondering where Luke Zuri and Ravi came
from Ravi is originally from India and
Zuri was adopted from Uganda Africa but
we'll let Luke explain where he is from
in this episode Jessie decided to go to
the park alone with the three other kids
they quickly found something else to do
when she started playing music and when
Luke came back she asked him where he
was from he said that his parents said
the stork brought him but the seventh
graders had a more interesting theory
then Jessie asked him not to talk to
seventh graders if you ever had the talk
with your parents you know what they're
talking about but this episode wasn't
really about where Luke came from it was
about where he was going when a man saw
their performance in the park and
offered them to make a music video
Jessie and Luke
that they had the chance to become stars
but little did they know this guy was
only a scam artist that's at least one
good life lesson that we learned from
that episode the touch in this sitcom we
hear a lot of inappropriate jokes when
it comes to touching the first one was
from the third episode of the first
season used karma this time
Emma discovered that Tony had a crush on
Jessie by reading a magazine she talked
about the different body parts where he
could touch her and what it would mean
about their relationship and Jessie
answered that all she cares about is
that he doesn't touch her end zone and
all the grown-ups know what she was
talking about now that would certainly
mean that he wants to be more than
friends after their date she even
accused him of trying to get this all
day long until she realized that he just
wanted to be a good friend then in the
17th episode bad fellas a not so nice
guy asked Jessie if she could pat him
down as it would be the highlight of her
week but the most inappropriate joke
actually came from Surrey in tempest in
a teacup
when Tony said that he was going to have
fun with Jessie Zuri told him to keep
his hands for himself she made sure that
they were north to the equator but not
that far north mister we don't know what
Jessie would be doing without her the
romance everything just got
inappropriate in this episode for if the
main characters are kids and Jessie is
their nanny so you wouldn't expect them
to do too many things your parents
wouldn't like you to watch but when two
adults got together on a date things got
a little out of hand in this episode
Jessie lost an expensive tiara and it
was found by mrs. Chesterfield this is
why Bertram had to invite her on a date
so Jessie would keep her job the butler
wasn't comfortable but he certainly
played the game trying to distract this
strange lady he said that she brought
out the animal in him dancing
passionately with her then he said that
they couldn't leave the kitchen because
his garlic bread was burning and mrs.
Chesterfield pressed her buns against
his lap saying that she knows exactly
how it feels even if it looked like
things were getting hot in here the
woman was probably disappointed to see
that she couldn't feel the bread in his
pants they were almost done with dinner
and Zuri said that she knew what mrs.
Chesterfield wanted for dessert
Bertram ala mode and grown-ups all know
what it means to eat a man on a date if
you want to see more inappropriate jokes
you have to watch romancing the Crone
we're just happy that our parents
weren't there when we saw it on TV the
dress we all know that Debbie Ryan is a
really beautiful young woman it was no
surprise that a boy like Luke would fall
in love with her The Nanny is usually
wearing something appropriate
but we first saw one outfit that our
parents wouldn't like us to wear in one
day wonders while being the victim of a
scam artist who offered to film a music
video for $1,200 she was wearing
something a little too mature for Disney
Channel a red short dress she even said
that she was wearing a dress that in her
hometown would get her arrested and all
the grown-ups knew what she would look
like if she walked down the street in
that outfit but we think that women
shouldn't be ashamed of wearing whatever
they want men are the ones who should
look at them in a different way
mostly when they are 6 years younger
than their nanny in a hundred and one
lizards the boy made one more awkward
comment when they were in a zoo Jesse
said that she felt like she was being
watched and Luke told her that she
should expect that when she is wearing
that dress and she said that she didn't
mean that she was watched by him we
think that women should have the chance
to wear whatever makes them feel good in
their own skin the only things that
should stop are the comments that are
making them feel uncomfortable the video
we all know that Luke is just obsessed
with Jessie and that he loves watching
this beautiful young woman he made that
clear in season 1 in glue done it a
sticky situation when the kids found out
that Jessie was guilty of a crime Luke
suggested that they should be using a
nanny cam to keep an eye on her and he
asked to be the one monitoring all the
footage this kid was really excited so
we bet that he was talking about things
only adults should see and he made his
dream come true in the second season in
Jesse's big break Jesse got a role as a
stunt performer in a movie and Luke
decided that he was going to be filming
her too and he admitted that this time
he was not doing it in a creepy without
their knowledge kind of way so what has
he been doing before was he filming her
in her sleep when she was taking a
shower
or just at any time of the day around
the house Jesse noticed that he was
drooling just by looking at them
so we bet that he was secretly filming
something guys are really interested in
and the other actress even had to ask
him to film their faces instead we think
it means that Luke was filming their
breath
keep dreaming young man you might have
the chance to look but you'll never have
the chance to touch the bottom when they
want to refer to the bottom Disney
characters can't use a word that starts
with the letter A but that doesn't keep
them from using other words that sound
just like it so everyone can understand
what they mean for example in the first
episode of the first season emma was
disappointed that her parents couldn't
make it to the science fair
Jesse convinced her that the distance
will never keep them from loving each
other and then encouraged the young girl
to kick some asteroids she might sound
like she was referring to something that
we can
we find in space but we know that she
was talking about something we all have
on earth then in the second episode we
heard Robbie talk about some pain in the
ashram we all know what it meant but if
you don't believe that they're always
almost using bad words just wait until
you see episode 13 of season 2 to be me
or not to be me this time Zuri was in
Jesse's body and said that the director
would look ridiculous with her foot up
his and this was when she stopped
talking but we all know the three-letter
word that she was going to say they
might never say the word but it makes us
think about it every time so we would
say that this is an inappropriate joke
the smile when it comes to health class
we know that kids love to make fun of
this topic and Luke Ross is not an
exception we first heard one of these
jokes in season one episode 26 the
secret of mr. Kipling when they found
out that the lizard was actually a girl
and that she was having babies Luke said
that unless he totally misunderstood
health class there has to be a dude
lizard involved we hope that parents
won't have to have the talk with their
kids because of that then we got another
health class joke in season two in
diarrhea of a mad news woman and it was
more inappropriate than everything we
have ever heard before
this time mo revealed to the school that
their hamburgers were actually made of
horse meat and this is why everyone
started applauding her in the hallway
then Luke said that he hasn't seen that
many smiles since that health class
video mix-up as our teachers are
supposed to tell us what couples do in
bed at night we were afraid that they
actually showed them a video of what
it's like to make babies and this is not
something that anyone under 18 years old
should see we can't believe that a boy
made that joke on Disney Channel are
there any other inappropriate jokes that
we missed don't be shy to tell us what
it is in the comment section down below
we'd love to know what you think and
that's it for 10 inappropriate jokes in
Jesse for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 inappropriate jokes in
good luck charlie thanks for watching
[Music]